all right guys bang-bang I'm here with
Chris dude thank you so much for coming
this gonna be fun
thanks for having me all right you uh
you had a life prior to your work at the
Ohio government what were we doing sure
so I kind of I guess real quick
backstory on Me's I grew up born in
Atlanta Georgia so a big college
football fan unit are you a University
of Georgia fan I am go Dawgs
yeah well go Gators but good okay all
right we'll see in late October
so the Gators won't be there we so I
born in Atlanta grew up though in
Northeast Ohio right went to school in
southwest Ohio Miami of Ohio
Miami University the fitnah fake Miami
gonna fake Miami although Miami
University was a was a University when
Florida still belonged to Spain yeah say
you can buy that on the t-shirt rack at
the school shop they're not I love that
but so went to Miami University I've
always kind of you know I guess I'm a
pretty big nerd and geek so I'm always
been into like history and government so
why is that Miami that was kind of like
what I went deep into a big fan of that
stuff so I actually my first job out of
college moved to Washington DC worked on
Capitol Hill for a couple years what
does that mean so I worked for a member
of Congress that was you know first job
out of college so like 20 years old
nothing important but you work in a
museum and it's awesome you know lived
on Capitol Hill so I'd walk to work
every day passing the Supreme Court you
know the US Capitol the office building
so it's just absolutely a phenomenal
first job what do you do so like I'm
fascinated by this idea that you know
humans run run the government yeah I
think people forget that sometimes
they're you know people want to rage
against the government and all the
decisions that are made in the
implications of them but there are
humans that are actually you know
evaluating different opportunities or
different options and they vote and the
whole kind of democratic process to some
degree but there's a bunch of support
staff right and so like it would be
literally impossible to let's say for a
congressman to read every single piece
of paper to kind of take every meeting
etc
like walk us through like how does the
the staff of a congressman help right or
what's that day-to-day look like yeah
and so it's a great question what's wild
about that is most staffers from members
of Congress especially in the House of
Representatives there are in their 20s
so really probably anywhere from 20 to
kind of first job out of college like I
was to mid maybe late 20s and the thing
is is that that's a town where there's
so much turnover it's expensive it's
like in New York City it's like a San
Francisco so a lot of these you know
staffers they'll work there a couple
years and then they'll go get a job for
twenty five thirty five thousand dollars
more go work downtown as a lobbyist or
worked on it like a PR shop yeah
so to work on Capitol Hill especially on
that house side it's really young if you
walk through the halls I mean you think
like it's college intern season and and
that's and that's what's wild because
it's super interesting so your point of
like they're the ones that are helping
these members of Congress and you know
yeah some members of Congress have been
there for years know what's going on but
for the most part especially if they're
a freshman are kind of in that you know
second or third or fourth year they're
not experts on it so they rely on staff
and when they're relying on staff and
those guys are 20 years old it's kind of
scary when you think about it I mean it
really is thank God for checks and
balances but it's it's a little wild
I can imagine there's some 22 year olds
of some wild-ass ideas on Capitol Hill
oh yeah yeah and you go to a you know
kind of a after work happy hour bar and
it's a it's kind of a wild place that's
yeah well I think that uh what is it the
male brain is it fully developed until
you're like 28 or something so like you
have literally 22 to 25 let's call it
congressional staffers without fully
developed brains yeah pretty crazy
literally an entire office could have
everyone under 30 years old and if that
member of Congress is again in their
first term their freshman you know maybe
they were like a doctor or they were a
business person before they don't really
know how Washington works yeah so the
relying on an entire set of staff to
help guide the way and that's why
lobbying has such a huge influence on
what goes on in Washington because
really those are the folks that have
been around for decades kind of know
what the different fights are like and
they're the ones that can help walk
people through it so that's you know if
you kind of think of why is Washington
broken
big part of it is staff don't get paid
enough so they all leave and we have 25
year olds right exactly it's not literal
is it like the prisoners are running the
asylum yeah it's I mean anyone that's in
DC just go walk around Capitol Hill and
you're gonna see like a bunch of kids
and it's like their field trips like now
they work here Wow all right so and then
what do they do the kind of daily basis
like you know do you hear the horror
stories of like oh somebody like
presented this piece of legislation it's
gonna get voted on in four hours it's
500 pages like the staffers I'll try to
like redo it as quickly as possible and
give feedback to the congressional
representative I'm assuming that that's
few and far between it happens but but
probably not as often as people think
but is it just a lot of like reading
legislation and and kind of like talking
or what's that dated yeah so most of its
really meeting with your constituents
okay so you know in Congress the
leadership they're the ones that really
run the show so probably 95 percent of
members of Congress but again in the
house the Senate's different there's
only a hundred of them so they all can
go get a microphone and that's where a
ton of the influences is just from like
your PR strategy but if you're in the
house most of them don't have much
impact so a lot of it's just meeting
with your constituents you know people
are flying in they're meeting with like
different groups that have you know some
type of bill they're interested and you
know if you're from Ohio like I am they
fly in from Columbus they fly in from
Cleveland but to your point of kind of
like what's it like it's really funny so
you know most people in Washington DC
they either think that they're living in
the West Wing or house of cards but in
reality it's more like veep because it's
just such a joke so many people take
themselves so seriously
now get a lot of people do good work but
it is much more like veep than it is
house of cards or the west wing did you
see that the new Ukrainian president is
oh yeah the best known comedian yeah
right my theory is that comedians are
just people who tell the truth right I
mean people really appreciate that
you're seeing it not just in Ukraine
it's all over so it's it's definitely a
wild time for sure well it's also this
element of like you know the person who
controls the meme controls the message
yeah and I think we're seeing that you
know if you look at everything from
Donald Trump to AOC like the people who
have figured out how to use these
channels for communication and to
control the you know quote-unquote me
they really do control the message when
it comes to kind of the political
conversation absolutely it's all about
the microphone and who has it and who's
able to utilize it and again you know
whether you're Republican Democrat you
know libertarian vegetarian anything in
between it's really about who has the
best messaging strategy for the most
part you know Donald Trump's great at at
AOC is great at it a lot of you know
most people aren't great at it and
that's why you see you know a Oh see a
freshman Democrat from New York City who
doesn't have a huge you know she's not
the chairman of a committee she's not in
charge of really anything but she has
millions of followers because she's
figured out a way to kind of hack the
system and stand out from everyone else
and you know kudos to her for that
absolutely you know it makes a lot of
sense all right so let's talk about
technology in Washington and kind of
especially the halls of Congress and the
house representatives what the hell is
going on do they understand kind of all
of these new technologies not just
blockchain but
autonomous cars you know CRISPR right
all these things that are kind of the
very innovative or bleeding edge of
innovation do they get it that's a great
question I don't know um I think that
are they talking about it I think
they're start talking about ok
definitely and again that's where you
know you kind of look who's you know
again most of its who has the messaging
you know the biggest microphone and then
the money and really the money is these
tech firms and you see tech firms more
and more realizing the importance of
what they need to do to stand out in
Washington because what happens is if
your Facebook your CEO Mark Zuckerberg
he gets called in front of Congress go
testify and that no one wants to do that
that wastes time so fly across the
country he's got to prepare for it he
could look you know he could get totally
embarrassed so the tech companies are
spending a ton of money on lobbying and
they're figuring out a way to you know
share their message and make sure
they're kind of shaping the narrative
and getting their information out there
so the the info it's definitely being
talked about it's just a matter of kind
of who's controlling it and who's doing
something about it and a lot of times
you know it's again it's money and who
has money these days and it's the big
tech players out in Silicon Valley yeah
makes a lot of sense and when you talk
about the constituents I'm assuming that
most of it is the constituents coming to
Washington and so if you're traveling to
tell your representative about your
shoes or things you care about you have
to have some level of affluent behavior
or means right just in that you can
really get on a plane to go talk to
somebody and I'm guessing that a lot of
that is the higher tech type stuff the
big pharma you know all the things that
people kind of hear about Washington
that makes a lot of sense when you do
the reverse because I know that a lot of
Representatives do go back to their
actual kind of geographies what is that
is that like more like Town Hall type
stuff or the staffers involved in that
yeah kind of a very question
it completely varies from kind of
Congress to member of Congress and
honestly it probably a lot of it is what
type of district they represent so if
you're a Democrat and you're in a swing
district they're probably going to be
pretty careful about what they do and
how they're doing it back home because
yeah it may be great in theory to go
have a Town Hall but if all of a sudden
it becomes like a news hijacking where
you know a bunch of angry constituents
come out and take the microphone don't
let you talk that's what the local news
is going to run with so that's kind of
like you know these members of Congress
and their staff they have to evaluate
what they're going to do and how they're
going to do it and in politics
controlling that message is so important
and that's the same you know whether
you're building a big tech company
whether you're running a political
campaign or whether you know you're an
official member of Congress because if
someone is hijacking your story you've
just lost all control and right now as
we've seen you know Democrats just took
over the House Republicans kept the
Senate but there isn't a lot of there
isn't a lot of reason for most members
of Congress if they're kind of in a
swing district they have to be very
careful what they do and how they do it
so there's a ton of thought and energy
put into how they're going to best
communicate it but then also protect
themselves because you know if you
remember Congress you're running for
re-election you never stop running it's
ever two years you know they say you
have to raise like ten thousand bucks
every week just to kind of stay in the
game and so you're not falling behind
yeah if you're if you're in the Senate
you have six years so you know they can
kind of take some time off and not
really focus on that but if you're in
the house it's a constant campaign which
you know is that good for democracy I
don't know yeah but it's definitely a
reality yeah makes a lot of sense
all right so why'd you leave so tired a
party afterward honestly it's probably
like New York it's probably like you
know the bay
we're know not many people are from DC
yeah and so that was awesome where
everyone's there kind of for the same
reason you know it's like Hollywood for
ugly people where you go to Hollywood
for like show business you go to
Washington because you like government
and politics and so it was awesome you
meet friends from literally all over the
country you kind of I lived with three
great buddies of mine the house next
door the townhouse next doors and other
four guys that were great friends but I
grew up in Ohio I'm close with my family
and it was just kind of the right timing
or Steve Jobs opened up and I was able
to kind of just leap at it and it was
just kind of the timing I think chose me
I think in an ideal world I would have
stayed a few more years the other kind
of fascinating thing with DC is it's
very easy to almost get stuck there in a
way because you know if you have all
this federal government experience well
how are you gonna like be a value to a
company outside of DC like your values
in DC and your network experience yeah
so it's you know your values are your
your skill sets don't exactly match so I
didn't want to necessarily get some ways
stuck there so I was like you know what
it's kind of the right time I had a
couple sisters you know I live in
Columbus now I had a couple sisters at
the time at Ohio State it kind of just
made sense I had a job offer I just went
with it
got it and and when you moved to
Columbus what do you do so I moved to
Columbus still kind of working in
government politics I worked at the Ohio
treasurer's office under the former
treasurer Josh Mandel he's a young guy
at the time he was like in his young 30s
I would say when I first started working
for him I did communications for him and
working for him was absolutely
fascinating because was grace it was
still kind of policy which I enjoyed but
it was also finance public finance
albeit but still finance so we were
doing a lot of interesting things and
he's a incredibly smart passionate and
just hard driving guy he's a former
Marine couple tours of duty in Iraq so
that's like kind of his go-get-'em
mentality and so we did a number of
really cool first of their kind of
Nishat 'iv that I don't think any
treasures before had done anything like
that none after and it's such a
important office I mean we collect
protect and investigates tax dollars so
I think we collected last fiscal year
sixty two and a half billion per
224 billion and then invested I think it
was twenty two and a half billion
alright so this is important let's
before we get into exactly here's your
dinner oh hi oh let's talk about just
the state treasurer's office in any
state you just said that you collect
protect and advance the taxes of a state
big numbers racially I'm out collecting
sixty plus billion protecting two
hundred plus billion and then you said I
think invest like twenty two and a half
okay
collecting right that's probably most of
the policy work is that correct in terms
of like how we're gonna collect it how
we're gonna count aid all that yeah so
with the collecting that's you know just
income taxes business taxes those types
of things they flow in our office would
then kind of a simplified version you
know send that out to the different
state agencies and whatnot or put those
in in different investment accounts so
then you know we could pay the bills we
could build the roads we could do
whatever needed to be done just to
operate the state if you think of it
like a company you know and so that's
you know the collect protect and invest
that's the core you know what you have
to do every day if you screw up you
can't do anything else you because you
know you have to do those things
correctly outside of that is where we're
able to kind of do these other kind of
interesting things with some
transparency investment accounts we
launched the nation's first investments
accounts for individuals with
disabilities so that was a very
rewarding thing to work on and then Ohio
crypto comm was kind of all right don't
get ahead of me hold on so collecting
policy stuff protecting what exactly
does that so that's the pension funds
for the state of Ohio there's five
pension funds you know police and fire
state employees teachers school employee
retirement Highway Patrol and so that's
there's five independent investment
funds we as the elected you know that
the treasurer he's the directly
accountable to the people and it was up
to him to make sure that he was a
kustodiev them we kind of oversaw make
sure that you know choosing some of the
banks we worked with and making sure
that you know the retirees have their
money mm-hmm makes sense and then
investing yep so there's a couple
different state investment portfolios we
had an investment team in-house now it's
state tax dollars you can't do anything
crazy so it's really conservatives to
type stuff bonds those types of things
but we had a
time dedicated team and every day
they're just going and invest and make
sure that you know we were able to put
money get a little bit of interest on it
you know what we always said for
investing was safety liquidity yield in
that order
because it's tax dollars she can't be
screwing around with it you know you
need to be able to get it but if we can
get a little something to kind of you
know increase what we're able to provide
for Ohioans we try to do it yeah kind of
so I'm guessing that that's for some I
ever coughed on their podcast shout out
to myself I'm assuming that most of the
returns are looking at car like
mid-single digit type stuff so fairly
low risk but office as you said kind of
the safety liquidity prioritizing
rehearsal got it okay all right so
that's all the what I'll call it table
stakes stuff every state treasurer's
office has to collect protect and invest
the funds in which they are entrusted
with you guys went above and beyond kind
of the call of duty if you will and you
guys did all kinds of wild stuff wild in
the framework of government but pretty
common sense I think from most people's
perspective that come from the
technology world let's talk first about
the transparency stuff yep maybe talk
about the website and how this kind of
sure yeah
so Ohio checkbook comm and my again my
former boss Josh Mandel he was the one
you know it's these are his ideas and we
helped him execute on him but Ohio
checkbook comm was the first time in
state history that we put every single
dollar that the state spends online so
there's two bucks for a pack of pencil
to millions of dollars in wrote
contracts everything in between but not
only did we do that but we designed this
website in a way that you didn't have to
be a PhD you didn't have to be a
computer scientist you don't have to
have a CPA in order to look and search
you could go on a Google style search
bar interactive charts and graphs would
go back 10 plus years and you could you
know type in Walt Disney World
see if there was some type of government
official that went to Walt Disney World
for a conference show up how much the
date it was who spent it you know all
the information you need so as a citizen
or an investigative journalist or anyone
that just cared about tax dollars you
could go in and see how this money was
being spent and it was so we what's
really funny about this story is Josh
made a policy decision in house that he
was going to
build this thing but build it in secret
while at the same time asking for
permission to do it so alright so I've
talked to Josh about yeah this is the
wildest part of the whole story is what
you just said the state treasurer as far
as I understand has the power to
unilaterally do this yep he did it in
terms of him and the rest of you as a
team together built this privately
writer yep behind closed doors at the
same time he was not shy about saying we
need to do this we need to do this and
I'll call it lobbying right you know the
other governmental officials and offices
saying that they need to do it my
understanding is that they were not
exactly excited about doing this which
is why he kind of in parallel was
building in anyways and then it sounds
like it was launched without the
approval you know without the blessing
of these other organizations and they
all freaked out yeah right
this took us about 18 months to build
okay and we built it in complete secrecy
where you know maybe less than 20 people
in this state knew about it and so as we
were building it Josh was also going
around the state talking to journalists
talking to members of the legislature
and he said hey I want this to be I want
the state legislature to acquire me Josh
Mandel the state treasurer of Ohio to
pass a law so I have to do this so he's
just talking about it in theory in
public and you know people who oh sure
we're happy about it that's a great idea
but nothing was really happening people
across the state really loved the idea
but typical kind of some politicians
bureaucrats they didn't really love it
and so as he was going around trying to
build support we were just building this
thing and so one day we just launched it
flip the switch Ohio checkbook comm live
and it kinda just blues people's minds
because they've never been done and the
journalists investigative reporters good
government citizen watchdogs builders
like whoa like what yeah this was like a
gangster movie yeah and that's like an
official government term right it is is
the idea that you build this thing
because really what it did was it didn't
necessarily
beause you know was it the treasurer's
office saying hey XYZ personal
organization is abusing public funds or
doing something nefarious or being a
good actor ready to kind of the whole
spectrum it simply gave the tools for
anyone else who wanted to look and it's
almost like there's confidence and
security and transparency right if yeah
if I know that I can go look then I am
much more likely to feel comfortable
than if I can't right and so any like
really visceral reactions from folks
privately yeah people were not happy
there are some members of the
legislature some members of kind of the
executive branch that did not like it
and really held it against us and it's
funny after we did it there are some
people that said well we were gonna do
it ourselves so we need you you know you
guys it's like well we've been talking
about this for 18 months why does it
take you another year to launch it yeah
but when you think about it one the big
thing is this is already public
information we didn't take any
information that wasn't already a matter
of public record that already belong to
taxpayers and we just put it online so
anyone could request it but you just
didn't have to go through all these
crazy steps to do it and second is if
you think about like the democratization
of finance and money
I mean this belongs to the people this
doesn't belong to bureaucrats they're
entrusted with it
but people should know how to do it and
people should also have confidence in
being able to search it and again not
have to be some type of computer expert
to go online and there's this
interesting report that we kind of think
was kind of resulted in it and
originally Ohio was 46th in the country
for government transparency and so we
kind of use this report to model it we
became number one so we went from 46 to
1 but the number two three and four and
five best sites I mean were light years
behind what we did and so we really kind
of flipped this thing on its head and
built this thing out in a way that not
only did it improve in Ohio but other
states were able to kind of follow and
they did and there was a number of other
states that started to kind of up the
ante and what we you know what we saw
was this race for transparency yeah I
mean look it so I've checked out it
obviously when I first met Josh and one
super impressive right too though just
the way that it kind of came
in the lodge and everything there's an
element of irony in like building a
transparency tool in secret yeah right
Rob but but uh but but obviously for
good reason and I think that the part
when you go to the web site that is just
kind of blows people's minds it's like
hey this is a government website but
it's actually intuitive that actually
has a great user experience and again to
your point the information was public to
a degree but there was a sense of
secrecy or difficulty that was baked
into the bureaucracy of getting the
information
well now anybody who knows how to type
can just go type in information and
missing stuff right yeah which i think
is pretty cool so all right so you guys
do Ohio checkbook comm and then it's
like you get your bolted right now you
guys like all right well that one went
pretty well
and then you move on to a high hope
crypto yeah tell us about that yeah so
high crypto calm that was kind of our
you know Josh he was a treasurer for
eight years and we had probably four or
five different first of their kind
initiatives Ohio crypto calm was
definitely the last and I would say in a
lot of ways perhaps the most successful
so we had probably we started building
Ohio crypto to accommodate in 2018 you
know so less than a year ago at this
point but what's interesting you know
being kind of on the finance side I
remember having meetings years ago in
the office hey what is this Bitcoin
where we get people together kind of
read the white paper and see like what
does this mean because we want to stay
on top of things even if we can't by law
invest in certain things we still want
to know what's going on so it was always
kind of in our mind what cryptocurrency
what Bitcoin was but Josh one day comes
in and says I've been thinking a lot
about this I want to make Ohio a leader
no one is doing this it will have
tremendous impact in the space it will
have tremendous impact for Ohio one we
can give tax payers another option to
which they can pay their taxes but to
and in some ways more importantly long
term we're able to plant a flag and show
that Ohio is open for innovation Ohio is
open and friendly to innovators and
entrepreneurs that are doing interesting
things like cryptocurrency that are in
Bitcoin space they're just doing things
that you know we're Ohio we don't we're
not Silicon Valley we're not Austin
Texas we're not New York City so we have
to think and do things a little bit
differently and it's doing things like
Ohio crypto comm where we made Ohio the
first state in the country to accept
cryptocurrency Bitcoin for tax payments
and it was business taxes business
direct um walk us through kind of as you
guys built it how does the product
actually work right so I go to Ohio
crypto comm I basically put like I'm sue
my EIN number and or something for my
business you tell me how much I owe and
then I just like you know send Bitcoin
to a wallet address or how does it work
yeah so it's real simple and easy and
what's really fascinating is we're
building this you know the first thing
you do when you attempt something was
kind of look around like well who's done
this before and we found there was a
couple towns in Switzerland we called
them up they didn't really speak English
so it was kind of starting from scratch
and so we just kind of had to chip away
every single day and figure out what
we're gonna do and you know as we were
starting it you know there may have been
like 12 steps began and Josh is always
harping like no we got to make this as
simple and easy and intuitive as
possible so yeah you're absolutely right
you go to Ohio crypto calm you're
entering your tax identification number
up will pop up what you have you take
your wallet that you already have you
can scan it pay it and a tax payment can
be done in like 90 seconds and so again
is the first time it had ever been done
but we wanted to make it again just like
Ohio checkbook calm so user friendly
that there wasn't there what we were not
giving people reasons to say no the
difficulty of the physical payment that
was not going to be a reason for someone
to say no to this that makes a lot of
sense and then what was the response
after it launches because it will be
forget today this was built in secret as
well it was yep okay so built in secret
you guys launched it no real warning to
anybody nope which one I think was
awesome because it caught even a crypto
community kind of off-balance right in
the sense that I remember the day at
launch everyone was like whoa this is
real right because the knock against
Bitcoin for the longest time was exactly
and pay your taxes well now you can't
now you can right but what was the
reaction among
you know kind of governmental officials
and organizations in the state of Ohio a
lot of interest o interest okay so not
negative or you know and that's what's
what's wild I would say the week and two
weeks after we launched that I don't
think we had a better week or two weeks
in the office for eight years Wow it was
fascinating to see the people from
literally across the world that had
interest of just what it was we were
kind of because you know being in a
governmental office you kind of see a
ton of different things where people
they're always throwing arrows at you
and you're just always kind of taking
shots left and right and so we're
building this thing but then also
expecting for that to come and so we do
it and then we just start talking to
people we talked to journalist we talked
to people in the space we talked to
business leaders we talked to everyone
about it and we build out communications
methods so we can tell people you know
for folks in the space you know we're
telling them the same Genesis and the
same information but information that
they specifically would like as we're
explaining it to business leaders hey
you can pay your taxes and this is how
so we're developing these communication
strategies to make sure we're hitting
you know the right messaging points for
everyone involved and so as we're
walking you know kind of going through
in that first week or two the the it was
really astonishing to see it and no one
really knocked us back on it which was
fascinating because we would expected
you know some political opponents of
Josh's perhaps the newspapers didn't
like because it deemed it too risky
maybe folks in the space didn't think we
went far enough with it but people were
just resoundingly positive about it and
that was so cool to see yeah it um I
think that it's something where Bitcoin
and crypto currencies get some positive
attention some negative attention right
the volatility you know all this retail
investing all this stuff when are you
tie it to hey you're a government
official organization and this is gonna
help us collect more taxes and then we
can use those funds to maybe fun things
you want to do right also in like
there's like a personal interest or a
professional interest in seeing it be
successful I think it changes the kind
of conversation a little bit how many
people were actually interested though
right in terms of not not like it have
any business
in Ohio actually said you know that's
something I want to do yeah so the I
would say the only downside for
personally working on this is by the
time we'd built this is ready to go only
launched it we only had a few weeks left
in Josh's administration you know which
coincided around Thanksgiving around
Christmas new year so we didn't really
kind of get to like really run with it
as much as we would have liked but we
had ten businesses I believe register
for it we had two while we were in those
couple weeks pay for it yep so the first
person was a man named Bernie Marino
he's a big business leader in Cleveland
he's actually in charge of the block
land initiative he was the first person
in America to pay his taxes the second
one and this was also fascinating and I
think shows the potential his
overstock.com
became the first Fortune 1000 company to
pay their taxes they do a ton of stuff
with cryptocurrency and they saw it
heard about it and they wanted to be the
first big business to do it yeah and so
to work with you know a local business
leader and then a national kind of
business fortune 1000 to pay their taxes
shoats I think the possibility and the
potential but also just it helped really
tie for us how many people this affects
it's from the small entrepreneur of two
or three people in Cincinnati Ohio
they're maybe building the next
cryptocurrency or blockchain product to
literally a Fortune 1000 companies kind
of everyone in between and so to kind of
get that that you know again it was only
to small sample size for the short
amount of time we had but that was
really rewarding and really cool to kind
of help move the conversation and help
show and I remember my parents when they
saw the for the overstock.com
announcement they called up and they're
like what's this crypto you know and I
kind of explained you and they're like
oh that's really interesting that's a
cool thing you guys worked on yeah look
I've met Bernie and enough so everyone
knows overstock and I think that it's
this element of it probably is not the
most prudent financial thing to do right
in in the short term just given how
regulations currently work taxes work
but I think that both of those you know
groups are for thinking and it's more of
the statement of hey you can now do this
right more so than like I'm trying to
optimize for every last you know basis
point of my finances with that said
though
hopefully this leads to other states and
eventually the federal government
following suit right absolutely and
that's the other thing it's you know
especially in Washington there's so much
negativity and just problems there and
that's a whole another conversation but
you know if you think about states are
the laboratories for democracy
hopefully states like Ohio as a leader
can help move that ball forward and also
because you know we sure what we did was
fine and great but if no one's second if
no one's third if no one's fourth and
others don't adopt it what we did
doesn't really matter so that's the big
thing is getting those people next and
who's next to kind of move that ball
because the regulatory environment isn't
great and in this space in particular
you know it's truly global marketplace
where yeah maybe people are in Tel Aviv
building a company or maybe they're in
Europe or Southeast Asia
well or Toronto is a huge one and for me
flying from Ohio it's quicker to fly to
Toronto than it is New York City yeah
and so what can we do you know as
policymakers or government officials or
even business and civic your self you
know you're moving that conversation but
what can we do so people are willing to
build their business here in America as
opposed to taking it outside the borders
and giving them a reason to do so yeah
make some a simple sense all right so
you guys left in mid-july I think right
but January I'm sorry mid January yeah
and when you did that
obviously tax season kind of follows
that right so yeah remains to be seen
kind of how many businesses etc have
have utilized the product but I think
everyone especially the crypto community
was was highly impressed and frankly
appreciative right that hey look
somebody got this across the the thing
would it be fair to say that Josh
yourself others on the team are like
bitcoiners right and like super crypto
enthusiasts or would you think it's more
of no we're just more we're trying to
figure out you know interesting
innovative technologies to use in
watching a Bitcoin happen to be one of
them yeah I know Josh is heard him say a
million times he's a crypto enthusiast I
find the technology fascinating and just
you know what is going to lead to and
just what does it mean and also just
being at the forefront of trying to
understand it and so you know not to
jump ahead but kind of what I do now is
help some of these companies
move the conversation move the ball
whether it's communications or you know
building out some messaging or branding
strategies because that's such an
important thing for anyone in the space
is you know it's great to kind of talk
to the same people and do the same
things but for the technology to move
forward it's it's how do you find others
outside of the you know the small you
know bubble so you can sell to those
people so you can get them to adopt it
whether that's you know doing small
things like Ohio crypto comm or
announcing partnerships with you know
you know the coffee shop down the street
to accept Bitcoin for your morning latte
or somehting kind of moving the
conversation and moving that ball down
the field is so important for this to
continue growing and that's something
that I find fascinating ya know I think
makes it and so now talk a little about
what you're doing right in terms of you
guys aren't just focused on Krypton I
think you're working with kind of all
kinds of different echnology things but
explain a little bit yeah so after I
after I left office in January we were
term-limited out so I was figuring out
what to do next and I decided to launch
a consulting company it's called the
green block group green block group comm
with my business partner Ari Lewis Ari's
been in this in the crypto space for
years and he's actually someone who I
met because he was a consultant that we
brought on for Ohio crypto comm so I met
him build it he helped build it because
in the office we had a ton of financial
professionals tons of you know IT
engineers that could actually build this
back-end but we didn't really have
anyone that was a true crypto insider
and knew and could talk it and could
help us walk through some of the you
know the opportunities and challenges
within it so we brought him on and he
was doing consulting after he was
winding off that project I was leaving
the office he was doing consulting I was
doing consulting we kept working more
and more together and realized why don't
we just join forces because as we were
working on this he was teaching me so
much from his perspective of you know
working in startups working in venture
working in this space I was teaching him
from you know the communications the
marketing the branding the the media the
government and so what we figured is
well what if we kind of offer a more
holistic set of experiences where
instead of someone just hiring a PR firm
or someone just hiring like an
implementation kind of expert you can
take our collective experience and
hopefully
provide a much better service to our
partners makes sense before I wrap up
yep it was asked around fire questions
I'm gonna skip some of the crypto
question heart and let you off the hook
what's the most important book you've
ever read though book I've ever read
that's a great question
I would so this is kind of a I'll go
with an author okay so I really like I
like reading like the big you know
history nerd and all that stuff but what
really helps me like get into a good
groove with reading is like mystery type
novels so I read a lot of John Grisham
oh yes probably my favorite author who's
not you know in history or government
that type of space and and another
reason I like it is every every
Christmas every holiday season I get a
new book from John Grisham that my mom
gives me and writes a little note in it
so it's like a tradition so it's it's I
love reading I'm in the middle of one
right now so I'll go with that I had
never read a John Grisham book but I
have seen who it is and there's a lot of
there's a time yeah so you've got a copy
yes covered in a lot of years all right
and then aliens believer non-believer oh
go no no Wow okay hold on I was big on
your your innovation there and now let's
say you're a non-believer why I'd like
to think we're special okay I also know
that I'm smart enough to not have any
clue what's going on in the world I mean
just that black hole photo that came out
even wrapping your mind around like what
the heck that was how they took that
it's real yeah I think it is because I
think there's just I agree that aside
real but I saw the kids but like what is
the immediately like I have no idea what
it means so are we going there that's I
mean if we go to the black hole that
happen idea have you seen the photo of
the two galaxies colliding no that's a
little scary
I got a city like this stuff is too big
for me to wrap my head around so I'll
just go no aliens
all right and then what about the ocean
like any desire to go to like the depths
of the ocean like everyone wants to go
always go to space but no depths of the
ocean oh no I
I think serving on like a some
mean like in the Navy I think that would
just be a cool no horrible oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] like it's just like I think it's
like really freaky or like trapped down
there if something goes yeah you're six
months I I mean I'm out I have no reason
to go down to the depths of the ocean
alright that's fair
alright psychopathy test how long the
dunk Oreos and milk whoo that's I just
had some Oreos this past weekend I would
say maybe like three to five seconds
okay you know just kind of like yeah
like I want to get it a little wet but
not too soggy anything also like I you
know you get I like dump um in but then
like have a spoon so then you're not
like no way no you put way you dunk them
in you throat men you can instead of
like dipping them with your hands where
you like dunk just throw it in let it
sit there for a couple seconds and then
like grab a spoon and like take it out
man you're the second person that is but
the other person I think it's Juan
Hernandez it was like I put them in and
I let them get super soggy eat it like
cereals even though I was like that's
not a psycho so yeah and if you leave
them in too long then you're like you
know okay but that's also probably like
eating pizza with a fork and knife which
is very much frowned upon yeah that's
fine all right three to five seconds
isn't it yeah um I think like seven
seconds is ideal okay the three to five
is like conservative but yeah you go
over the experience I wonder if it
varies with like the double stuff and oh
you just gotta just one size fits all
all right what one question you got for
me
let's see
good one question what do you what do
you you had a lot of great questions
about like policy like what do you think
from you know you're at the other end of
the spectrum of light gear the
technology face like I know nothing what
do you wish policy makers government
officials knew about this world that
they don't or what could you know the
space be better telling them I think
that every government official would be
better off if they took a one month
sabbatical every year and they had to go
spend it in like a externship type
situation with a company building some
sort of innovative technology they can
pick and there has to be some rule where
like congressional officials all can't
go work in big pharma right but like
again I'm making all this up top of my
head so you got to think it out more but
like maybe hey we'll send up to five
representatives to a single industry or
vertical but like some of them should go
figure out you know how does autonomous
driving work how does actual artificial
intelligence work how does robotics work
how does computer vision work right mhm
it's like all these different
technologies including Bitcoin and
crypto
I think that having leaders at the
govern a tional government level that
have a cult critical experience but it's
less experienced and more just like base
level knowledge of how some of this
stuff works and also having a network
that allows them to reach back out to
industry folks where oh we're talking
about like I don't know how to like set
up roads I don't know maybe I should
call like somebody's working on you know
it's how much driving at uber or Google
or Tesla or whatever right like that
seems to be like that should be a fairly
non-controversial way to look at it and
so it's less about like what do they
know and it's more about just like it's
very obvious that a lot of them are
unfamiliar with the like ground truth
with the innovative technologies and the
decisions they make today unfortunately
because of the bureaucracy because the
lead time needed for a lot of
implementations of their decisions those
technologies will actually impact what
they decide today 5-10 years from now
and so it just feels like if they're
blind to the tech and probably shouldn't
fix that I think that's just made it up
on the spot that's somebody on the
internet is gonna troll me and say
that's a bad idea I like it
alright man listen I really appreciated
I for for everyone in the crypto
community just thank you I think that
what you Josh the rest of the team did I
was pretty cool I think everything from
the transparency stuff to the crypto
stuff is
just a new way of looking at kind of you
know public finance right and hopefully
but many many more people will follow
yeah absolutely absolutely I mean I
appreciate so much your time thank you